time ted i was able to get a pumpkin
spice latte all the way into march and i
was like yes
i think i over did it though now i'm
like man welcome to las vegas right
all right i'd love to talk about that
but i gotta get right to some weather
yeah all right this just popped up and i
just put this out on social media too
severe thunderstorm warning for those of
you in bullhead city laughlin
catherine's landing this yellow box here
is that severe thunderstorm warning in
effect right now until six o'clock now
here's why we have this one cell that
just fired up and moved up towards you
in bullhead city and lachlan you're
getting 60 mile per hour gusts with this
look at all the lightning strikes along
with this too this one lonely spot here
producing 60 miles per hour gusts
lightning and also rain along with it
and it will be moving in a northerly
direction currently outside 103 for
centennial hills 99 in sumlin 108 for
downtown north las vegas included 107
for green valley 105 for southern
highlands down there in san diego valley
100 for you
laughlin still at 111
if we have some good rain with that this
number will drop even more all right we
get that rain cool there you'll drop
your numbers but the humidity will go up
here's our radar network i put several
radars working around sema sweeping
around you see these little icons here
that indicates where we're actually
getting some good storms and you can see
some icons all around the region right
now that's all as we zoom in you can see
exactly what's happening in the las
vegas valley most of the storms have
been really confined and we talked about
this these past few days that they would
really be stuck to the mountains where
they're really coming down right now for
the rain the lightning along with it
while we remain dry that one cell we had
over the northwest valley didn't last
long zooming out that high pressure that
we talked about too is right in the
sweet spot to allow those storms to come
up from the south you have the daytime
heating and that is the catalyst to
start those thunderstorms and that's
what we're seeing outside right now
futurecast does show slight chances of
those isolated cells still happening
look at that seven o'clock hour around
the valley for tonight and we get to
nine o'clock all that moves off and then
starts to die out tomorrow though we
have chances again once we get that
daytime heating to kick in maybe as
early as midday isolated chances in the
forecast also for tomorrow for your
friday and possibly in the mountains for
saturday before we dry out by the time
we get to late weekend and into early
next week so here's your forecast
isolated thunderstorms still a
possibility for early evening 83 degrees
overnight 103 for tomorrow partly cloudy
and muggy that's going to set us up for
more chances for isolated thunderstorms
for tomorrow now your numbers tomorrow
won't be as hot
but still above average 100 someone
tomorrow
102 north las vegas 105 sunrise manor
outside the valley will be at 100 for
prop 101 for boulder city your eight day
forecast you're eight on the eight
chances still exist through saturday
sunday we dry out numbers will drop but
still stay above normal but looks like
we're going to dry out for next week
that's your most accurate forecast brian
we'll send it over to you all right